hello
i'm rebecca sane a former title holder
in the miss and mrs america pageant
systems
and i'd like to welcome you to the world
of dr
joel wallach i'm one of many who has
been gifted with restored health
as a result of dr wallach's research and
nutritional products
millions have heard his message of
health and long life
others have heard his message of
nutrition and longevity
from his syndicated radio show his books
are his 300 plus
speaking engagements per year listen
closely and prepare to achieve your
ultimate in good health
it is my privilege to introduce
researcher
author lecturer and world-renowned
authority on health and longevity
dr joel wallach
how many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything to do
with livestock
well i'll tell you what you're my kind
of people because i grew up on a farm in
west st louis county and we started out
with beef calves
and uh if if you raise livestock the
only way you can make money is if you
raise a lot of your own feed for those
of you don't have that experience
and so we raised our own corn and we
raised our own soybeans in our own hay
and we had a truck come out from the
mill and this truck would come out from
the mill
and it would grind up the corn and the
soybeans and the hay and then we would
add
sacks of vitamins minerals trace
minerals and we'd make pellets out of it
and this is what we would feed the
calves
in six months time we'd ship them to
market to be slaughtered we'd save back
some of the best ones for ourselves
we'd knock them in the head and eat them
put it bluntly
and it always fascinated me as a
teenager that we did that for those
calves and in six months ship them off
to be slaughtered or we'd eat them and
we wanted to live to be a hundred years
of age without any
aches and pains and guess what we didn't
take any vitamins or minerals
and that bothered me so i asked my dad
i'd say hey pops
how come you do that for those calves
you don't do that for us
and he'd give me this good old missouri
farm wisdom he'd say things like
shut up boy you're getting this farm
fresh food and we hope you appreciate it
and of course i was very quiet then
because i didn't want to miss out on any
meals
well then when i went to school i went
to the university of missouri school of
agriculture and i got my degree in
agriculture
i got my major in animal husbandry and
nutrition
my minor was in field crops and soils
then i got into veterinary school
as a freshman veterinary student i've
learned the answer to my question
and the answer is this we know how to
prevent and cure diseases in animals
with nutrition
and the reason why we do that is because
we don't have major medical
we don't have hospitalization blue cross
blue shield
we don't have medicare if you're going
to make money as a farmer you better
know how to do stuff yourself and you
better
do it efficiently with feed and
nutrition if you can
to make a long story short after i got
out of veterinary
school i went to africa for two years
and i was able to fulfill a boyhood
dream i was able to be a frank buck for
two years
and work with marlon perkins many of you
will remember him from the mutual of
omaha's wild kingdom
and he's a great gentleman and after two
years of working with elephants and
rhino people used to ask me or
are you a small animal vet or a large
animal vet well i would tell them i'm an
extra large animal vet because i worked
with elephants and rhinos
well after two years he sent me a
telegram and said would you come back to
the saint louis zoo and work with us
we need a wildlife veterinarian at the
zoo for a special project
we were given a seven and a half million
dollar grant from the
national institutes of health and what
we need is a veterinarian who will do
autopsies of animals that die of natural
causes in the zoo
i was just overjoyed to do that and so i
came back and and of course i
not only did autopsies for animals that
died in the st louis zoo but the
brookfield zoo in chicago
the bronx zoo new york the national zoo
the la zoo and so forth
and my job again was to do autopsies of
animals that died of natural causes in
the zoo
and looked for a species of animals that
was ultra sensitive to pollution
this is because during the early 60s we
had just learned about pollution and
ecological problems and disasters
and nobody quite knew what to do and so
i was supposed to find a species of
animals it was extra sensitive
and used them much like we did the
canaries
in the mine you know the old welsh coal
miners used to put a canary in a little
wicker cage and take it down in the mine
and if methane gas
or carbon monoxide would leak into the
mine the canary would drop off the perch
and die first
and the men knew to get out before the
mine blew up or they suffocated
again to make a long story short over a
period of some 12 years
i did 17 500 autopsies and over 454
species of animals
and 3 000 human beings who lived in
close proximity to zoos
and the thing that i found out was this
every animal and human being who dies of
natural causes dies of a nutritional
deficiency
and that fascinated me went back took me
back to those calves i said gee that's
fascinating we could
document this at autopsy both chemically
and biochemically and things you saw
with the eye at the autopsy table well
that fascinated me and i wrote
scientific articles
i wrote eight multi-author textbooks and
one textbook of my own cost 140 bucks
for medical students
and i'm sure the only thing they do is
use them for door stops
and it couldn't get anybody excited i
was on 2020
i was on 1700 newspapers i was in
magazines it was in every network tv
that you can think of
and guess what couldn't get anybody
excited back in the 60s about nutrition
so what i did was went back to school
and became a physician
to use everything i had learned in
veterinary school about nutrition my
human patients
and to no surprise to me it worked i
spent 12 years up in portland oregon
in general practice and it was very
fascinating what i'm going to share with
you tonight is what i learned over those
12 years using nutrition with my human
patients
and if you take home only ten percent it
will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery it will save you a
gob of money and those of you in
missouri know what that means a gob
means a lot
okay it'll add many healthful years to
your life well you can't do this
you can't get these healthful years you
can't have longevity
you can't live to your genetic potential
just falling off a stump
you have to do some things the first
thing i have to do is convince you
that it is worth doing these things i'm
going to start out by convincing you
that the
genetic potential for human beings is
120 years our genetic potential for
longevity
in may 11th the oldest living american
at this time and documented
through the guinness world book of
records was margaret skeet she was from
radford
virginia she died at age 115 and
she died of a nutritional deficiency you
can tell that from her obituary
she died of the complications of a fall
what did she die from
osteoporosis very good she died of a
calcium deficiency she had no heart
disease no cancer
no diabetes no other infirmities but she
died three weeks after a fall because
she didn't have enough calcium
her daughter said that she had a craving
for sweets until she died and that's a
disease called pica we'll talk about
that a little bit but
usually when you have a craving for
chocolate if you're a chocoholic or a
sugar a holic
that means that you have a deficiency
then in a third world country in niger
in africa a chief by the name of bower
at age 126 was eulogized by one of his
wives
and she was bragging about him at his
death at age 126
he was still in possession of all his
own teeth okay so you assume that other
faculties are working too
then here's a gentleman uh from syria at
age 133 he died in july of 1993.
he fathered nine children after the age
of 80 and
this meant if you add up nine months for
each child in a year for breastfeeding
for each one and a year between each one
of the children
he was still fathering children after
age of a hundred so there's still hope
for you fellas
then those of you who like science in
november of 1993
those six biospherians came out of that
dome
in arizona they were in there for two
years three couples
and they were supposed to eat the
perfect food and recycle the atmosphere
and grow their own food and whatnot and
have no pollution in their water
or air or food and when they came out
they're examined by medical
gerontologists from ucla university of
california los angeles
they put all this information their
physical their blood work and so forth
into the medical computers at ucla
and the medical computers projected that
they could live to be 165 years old if
they continued to do
what they were doing so all of that just
says to you that
there's a there's a possibility you can
live to be 120 and when i grew up on the
farm we could grow 200
uh bushels of corn per acre and with all
the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did
you could make a profit if you grew 200
bushels per acre but if you only got 100
bushels per acre and put out that same
effort in the same
fertilizer cost you'd lose money and so
i want you to think about it the average
lifespan for an american today is 75.5
average life span for an md or a doctor
is 58.
you want to gain 20 years statistically
just don't go to medical school
you want to live to be 120 there's only
two basic things it's real simple two
things remember
number one you have to avoid the
pitfalls you have to not step on the
land mines i call it
and those are in the military you know
what that means you do something stupid
like step on one of those things you
kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily
of course if you play russian roulette
or smoke excessively or drink
excessively
or wear a black sweatsuit and run
down the middle of the highway at two
o'clock in the morning you're going to
get struck by a car
all of those things are foolhardy but
it's amazing how many tens of thousands
of people die in america from doing
those stupid things every year the last
thing i will share with you on that
subject of avoiding the land mines
i'd suggest very strongly to you that
you avoid going to doctors
and i'm going to back up that statement
which is a pretty strong statement from
ralph nader's group in
january of 1993 just about a year and a
half ago
january 13th he put out a news release
based on a three-year study on the
causes of death
in american hospitals and it was 1500
page report
this three-year study and i'm not going
to waste your time or mine by
going over the whole thing word for word
but the bottom line
says a lot quote three hundred thousand
americans are killed each year
in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence
unquote i'm going to read that figure
again because it's a huge figure
quote three hundred thousand americans
are killed each year in hospitals alone
as a result of medical negligence
unquote
he didn't say he slipped away quietly
out of neglect in a corner somewhere
while they're waiting for an x-ray he is
the word killed when you use the word
killed that means there was a procedure
the doctor was doing went wrong somehow
that means that they gave them a wrong
prescription they put a decimal point in
the wrong spot and gave them
an incorrect dosage these people were
killed
three hundred thousand to appreciate how
big a figure that is
you have to compare that with our
military losses in vietnam over ten
years
where we lost fifty 000 people over 10
years or an average of only 5
600 a year on a field of battle where
people had guns and artillery and
explosives trying to kill each other
and millions of people poured out into
the streets and protested that war
we had political anarchy in the last
three years of the war
students took over universities and
colleges with guns and explosives
national guardsmen shot students at kent
state in ohio
we chased the president out of the
presidency for 5
600 military personnel a year and here's
one profession that takes your tax money
in the form of medicare and medicaid and
kills three hundred thousand of us a
year according to ralph nader and i
believe him he has no extra grind
and you can go out in the street any day
of the week in any city and there isn't
even a
crazy street preacher out there with a
sign that says protect us from doctors
i want you to think about that folks
that's number one you have to avoid
stepping on the land mine so there's a
certain value in treating yourself when
you can
are preventing disease so you don't have
to get treated now the second thing you
have to do number two is you have to do
the positive things
you have to do the positive things and
i'm gonna
start out here by just putting a figure
up on the board it's the number 90
and you need 90 nutrients in your diet
every day you need 60 minerals
you need 16 vitamins you need 12
essential amino acids or protein
building blocks
and you need three essential fatty acids
you need
90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're going to get a
deficiency disease if you don't have
them
in complete numbers and optimal amounts
i can tell you that i was
one of those nerds back when i was in
college i had a clipboard we didn't have
computers back then
so i had a clipboard and i was one of
those funny guys with glasses and
would walk up and down in the student
union there in columbia and say do you
take vitamins and minerals
i was still fascinated by that and and
of course people kind of look at you
crazy and say well yeah i take vitamin e
and i'd wait for them to come up with
the other 89 and they didn't they just
oh i take vitamin e
well today if you ask people do you take
food supplements they say oh yeah i take
tums
because that's what you know they hear
all the time well again you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it
but the newspaper is no and the
magazines and tv and radio knows
that we're interested in health and
longevity and
and supplements so they all talk to us
not because the medical profession has
asked them to do that in their stead
the medical profession doesn't say hey
we're so busy saving people with surgery
and chemotherapy and radiation
and pharmaceuticals would you please
educate the people on nutrition
they do it because it sells newspapers
well my favorite article of all time
appeared in time magazine april 6th
1992 and if you haven't read it i'd urge
you to get it out of a school library or
public library and photocopy it
stick one copy on the door in the
bathroom and one on the refrigerator
it's a cover article it says the real
power of vitamins new research
shows they may help fight cancer heart
disease and the ravages of aging
again there are six positive pages in
here there's only one negative sentence
and was issued by a medical doctor who
was asked by the writer of the article
what do you think
what do you think about vitamins and
minerals for people as food supplements
and here's what the doctor said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do you any good
sniffs dr victor herbert
a professor of medicine at new york
city's mount sinai medical school
we get all the vitamins we need in our
diets and taking supplements just gives
you expensive urine
unquote well to give you a missouri
translation of that
that means you're just peeing away your
dollars if you take vitamins and
minerals
you might as well wad up your dollars
and throw them in the toilet and flush
them away because you're not getting any
redeeming value from it those quacks are
just taking your money for those
vitamins and minerals
that's what he was trying to say got
published
so it must be true right after having
done those 17
500 autopsies and 454 species of animals
from around the world and 3 000 humans
and liking to be healthy myself and
having children and
grandchildren and not too distant future
children i'd rather pee out
50 cents or a dollar day worth of excess
vitamins and minerals it's pretty cheap
insurance
if you don't invest in yourself to the
tune of a buck a day for vitamins and
minerals guess what
you're going to invest in the lifestyle
of md somewhere
because when you pay the medical doctor
your fee for going to see him
not one penny that goes to study how to
diagnose or treat or prevent a
catastrophic disease in a little child
like who was in here earlier
or how to prevent or diagnose or treat
better breast cancer
prostate cancer in adults guess what
that money goes for pays the doctor's
mortgage
makes his mercedes payment it pays the
tuition for his kids to go to medical
school at have it you know have it is up
in boston
pays a tuition for his kids to go to law
school at yale
between 1776 and the second world war
the u.s government spent 80 million
dollars on health care and health care
research and studies
right now we're 1.2 trillion dollars a
year
for health care and it's free
we all know it's free right it's not
free but we're supposed to believe it's
free and everybody wants more of it and
more free stuff i'll tell you what if we
used a human type medical system
for the agricultural industry in the
livestock your hamburger cost 275
dollars a pound
on the other hand if you use the
agricultural
health system that we use in animals for
humans your monthly insurance premiums
for a family of five would be ten
dollars a month
you take your choice well i believe
since we've made them wealthy
through insurance programs and
government subsidies i believe they owe
us something i believe they owe us at
least as much as the
industries do according to for instance
recall notices
this was started of course i don't know
25 years ago when ralph nader
learned that the ford motor company had
made a pinto car with a rear end gas
tank that would blow up
when he got hit from behind at 20 miles
an hour fry everybody in the car
and when people complained to ford motor
company they said well you're just dumb
for getting in a car accident
we're not going to pay you for that
ralph nader says no it's a faulty design
so he went to a federal court and the
judge agreed with him and
through a court order forced ford motor
company to send everybody
a recall notice with a registered letter
bring that car in and they'll fix it for
nothing
but they kill 300 000 a year and nobody
protests as long as we get ours free
and that scares me that attitude at any
rate
i've got a bunch of these recall notices
you should have gotten over the last
couple years we'll go through them
quickly
number one is ulcers how many of you
ever heard that ulcers is caused by
stress
okay everybody's heard that if you don't
raise your hand you've got alzheimer's
or your fibbin right
well we knew 50 years ago in in the
veterinary industry that
ulcers at least in pigs was caused by
bacteria called helicobacter pylori and
of course we couldn't get one of these
high-priced stomach surgeons from mayo
clinic in fact we always used to yell
hold the mayo
when they say stuff like that otherwise
your pork chops would be 275 dollars a
pound to pay for that kind of surgery
and we learned that with a trace mineral
called bismuth and the tetracycline
antibiotic that we could prevent and and
cure
those stomach ulcers and pigs without
surgery so that's what we did cost
five bucks to cure a pig of stomach
ulcers with
bismuth the trace mineral and
tetracycline well the national
institutes of health now not the
national enquirer
but the national institutes of health
came out in february 1994 and said
ulcers are caused by a bacteria called
helicobacter pylori not stress
and they can be cured they actually use
the cure word in this news release
medical researchers never do that they
always say shows promising results or
may be beneficial
they use the cure word national
institutes of health and they say can be
cured with a combination of the trace
mineral bismuth and tetracycline
well for those of you don't know what
bismuth comes in you can get it from any
grocery store or drugstore it's pink
about 295 for an eight ounce bottle and
it's called pepto
bismol so a teaspoon a day full of
pepto-bismol and some
oreomycin calf scour pellets you can
take care ulcers
now you have your choice where you're
going to treat your own for five bucks
or go get
whittled on that's your choice then
what's the number two cause of death in
americans terrible disease called cancer
right
now doctors get information on cancer
you'd think they'd photocopy that when
they send you that bill
they should send you some photocopies of
this stuff well in september of 1993
the national cancer institute not the
national enquirer but the national
cancer institute
and the um have at medical school in
boston
did a study on cancer patients and they
came out and they said an anti-cancer
diet was found
well any rate they picked china to do
this study because
in one province henan province and china
they have the highest rate
of cancer in the whole world they took
twenty nine thousand people for five
years in this study
and what they did was give them
different vitamins and minerals at
double the recommended daily allowance
for americans
now that's a trivial amount for instance
they use vitamin c for one group and
of course the rda recommended daily
allowance for vitamin c is 60 milligrams
double that's going to be 120 milligrams
you can't go into a health food store
and find a
vitamin c tablet or capsule for less
than 500 milligrams for an adult
of course linus pauling the gentleman
with two nobel prizes says if you want
to prevent and treat cancer with vitamin
c you got to use
10 000 milligrams a day well all the
doctors who used to argue with him back
35 years ago are all dead
and today linus pauling's still 94 and
he works 14 hours a day seven days a
week on his ranch in the big sur
in california and teaches at the
university of california san francisco
so you have to make up your choice
whether you're going to listen to the
dead doctors or linus pauling
your choice okay vitamin c double the
rda nothing happened vitamin a double
the rda nothing happened zinc riboflavin
the trace mineral molybdenum niacin
nothing happened
in one group they got a major benefit in
this group they got three nutrients at
one time they got
vitamin e they got beta-carotene and the
trace mineral selenium
those three were at double the rda and
if you get
a half a percent benefit in any
nutritional or pharmaceutical experiment
you've made a major improvement in
humanity's
life and so these articles get published
so once you remember that statistic a
half a percent
is major benefit well in this group that
received the vitamin e beta carotene and
selenium for five years
deaths from all causes were reduced by
nine percent
almost ten out of every hundred or one
out of every ten who were going to die
in that five years
from any cause survived then cancers all
cancers
thirteen percent survived who would have
died without those three nutrients
so 13 out of 100 lived who would have
died and then the type of cancer that
was most prevalent in henon province
stomach and esophageal cancer 21 lived
who would have died
21 out of 100 lived now to me those are
significant numbers
and your physician for the number two
cause of death in america should have
sent
every one of you a photocopy that at
least giving the information even if he
didn't want to give you the advice give
you the information let you make up your
own mind
well here's one i think is funny on one
hand and on the other
side it tells you the attitude of
physicians
this has to do with arthritis it was in
september 24th 1993 that it was released
again it was from the habit medical
school and the bastion va hospital
how many of you in here have ever been
to a va hospital anybody in this room
okay good well you know the people
who've been to a va hospital you have
two opportunities to give your life for
your country
once on the field of battle and the
others in the va hospital right
well any rate the title of the release
was chicken protein halts the swelling
and pain of arthritis in a patient trial
and what they did they took people who
failed to respond in any way to medical
treatment for arthritis
these people got gold shots mesotrexate
they got
aspirin prednisone cortisone everything
else you can think of physical therapy
and the only thing left for them was
joint replacement surgery
okay now before harvard medical school
and the va hospital was going to give it
to him they said look
we're looking for some people who are
willing to suffer for 90 more days just
three months
because we want to try something a short
term experiment and they got 29
volunteers
what they did for those 29 volunteers
who failed to respond in any way to
medical treatment for arthritis
was they gave them a heaping teaspoon
full of ground up dried chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning
just a heaping teaspoon of ground up
chicken cartilage
and in 10 days according to harvard
medical school all the pain and
inflammation was gone
these are people who didn't respond in
any way to medical treatment
in 30 days they could open up a new
pickle jar that never been opened
and 90 days three months they had
maximum return
of function here's the funny part the
funny part
comes by a statement of the guy who was
the director of that study from harvard
medical school and here's what he said
quote listen to the words
very important quote after three months
it was clear that the drug was
beneficial unquote
because it worked chicken cartilage had
become a drug
you can see he's thinking about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with
300 bucks a capsule 20 patients and you
can just see him
calculating right that means if you go
to kentucky fried chicken and you buy a
bucket of chicken throw away the skin
and the meat and eat the ends off the
bones
you're practicing medicine without a
license
and if you go to a kentucky fried
chicken in the middle of the night in
the dark of the night and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you
collect two five gallon feed buckets
full of chicken bones
and you take them home with a hammer and
you pound off the ends of those bones
and dry your own cartilage in the
microwave you know
you're manufacturing a pharmaceutical
and the fda is going to put you in jail
next time i come by here in three months
you're going to run up on this stage and
hug me and kiss me if you've got
arthritis
how many of you ever heard of
alzheimer's disease everybody's heard
about it today
50 years ago when i was a little kid
there's no such thing as alzheimer's
disease it's a new
disease one of those things that just
sort of happened now it's a major
disease
one out of every two people who reach
age 70 get alzheimer's disease pretty
scary
we learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages alzheimer's disease and
livestock
you imagine how much a farmer would lose
if the pigs were all laying there
scratching their heads saying
why am i here
[Music]
where is the feed box because if they're
not gaining a couple of pounds a day
you're losing money right so we learned
in the agricultural industry
how to prevent in the early stages cure
alzheimer's disease we do it with high
doses of vitamin e
and low intakes of vegetable oil you say
well like that's crazy high doses of
vitamin e well you should have got a
recall notice from your doctor
in july of 1992 because the university
of california
i mean we're talking about sophisticated
research medical school here
university of california san diego came
out and said vitamin e
eases memory loss and alzheimer's
victims now they're only 50 years behind
on that from veterinary medicine so it
might be safer going to a veterinarian
then how many of you in this room ever
had a kidney stone anybody in here ever
get that kidney stone okay i see a few
in here what's the first thing a doctor
told you to give up nutritionally
when you got your kidney stone give up
calcium no dairy
no dairy none of those vitamin mineral
things with calcium in them
because they have the stupid naive
ignorant belief
that's pretty intense they have the
stupid
ignorant naive belief that the calcium
in your kidney stone
comes from the calcium you eat when in
fact it comes from your own bones when
you have a raging calcium deficiency a
raging osteoporosis
then you get kidney stones we learned
years ago in writing in the agricultural
industry if you wanted to prevent kidney
stones and livestock you better give
them more calcium
you better give them more magnesium and
more boron
the reason is of course bulls and rams
male cattle and sheep have special
anatomy when they get a kidney stone
they die they call water belly
they die when you and i get a kidney
stone we just wish we were dead
but no farmer is dumb enough to pay for
the feed for an animal and have it die
before you can either eat it or send it
to market
so we learned how to prevent those
things well you should have got a recall
notice from your doctor especially you
people who've had kidney stones your
urologist
should have sent a notice to you this
was
march of 1993 it says calcium limits
kidney stone risk and this is from the
havit medical school up in boston by the
way
in a study that turns conventional
medical wisdom on its head researchers
have found that people whose diets are
rich in calcium run a reduced risk of
developing kidney stones
in a study more than forty five thousand
people who were ranked into five
categories the group that had the most
calcium
had no kidney stones now about five
years ago when i started out on this
crusade and started lecturing to people
all across america and i'm in one time
zone in the next and
all over i knew i was going to get crazy
out there
doing this last year i was on the road
300 days out of the year 300 out of 365
days
and so i decided i needed to have a
hobby that i could take with me every
time i get a little wacko i could
go in my room and do this hobby and i'd
be okay you know be kinda like having a
little piece of home with me wherever i
went
i wanted to have a hobby that would help
other people i didn't want to collect
baseball cards because i like football
and i didn't want to do just crossword
puzzles because good mental exercise but
wouldn't help anybody else
and i couldn't take my compost pile i
like to garden and
hotels don't like that you know so i
decided i was going to collect
obituaries of doctors and lawyers
now as crazy as that sounds remember i
told you the doctors lived to an average
age of 58 and we live to 75.5
and here's a group of people
professionals who pontificate
you and tell you well this is what you
need to do you need to give up salt and
no caffeine and you need to not eat
butter and eat margarine and do all
these crazy things
and they die at age 58 on the average
anyway got a few of them here some of my
favorites so this is dr stuart
cartwright age 38
he dropped dead in his home he was a
family practitioner
of a ruptured aneurysm that's a
ballooning of an artery that's a
weakened
artery because of the fragmenting or the
brittle condition of the elastic fibers
and arteries
just like when you hit a chuck hole with
your car tire and you break the cords in
there and you get a balloon
he dropped dead like he was poll axed
okay right in his home
from a ruptured aneurysm and we learned
in 19
oh i think it was uh 57
aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency we had a pilot project
turkeys we made complete food pellets
where you put
all the 90 nutrients in there and the
first 13 weeks
fully half of those turkeys died farmers
were out there every morning picking
them up by the bushel basket
they took them to the state diagnostic
labs in their autopsy and they found out
that they all had died
from a ruptured aortic aneurysm so they
doubled the amount of copper in there
and the next year they didn't lose a
single turkey from a ruptured aortic
aneurysm
and they ran that experiment and mice
and rats and rabbits and dogs and cats
and
uh calves and sheep and pigs and whatnot
and guess what they found out that
there's a whole series of diseases that
are caused by a copper deficiency
gray hair is the first sign when you
start getting gray hair regardless of
your age you've got a copper deficiency
you get skin wrinkles because the
elastic fibers in your skin are going
those little crows feet around your eyes
and
facial and body skin wrinkles you look
like you're a little prune drying up
okay then of course there's the
varicose veins that's caused by an
elastic fiber breakdown
then of course parts of your body begin
to sag under your arms your breasts your
bellies your legs all this stuff starts
sagging
and you can go to a cosmetic surgeon or
plastic surgeon if you want but
it's a lot cheaper and a lot more
effective and a lot safer if you just
take some
copper dr cartwright may have had a
medical degree but he didn't have
expensive urine so he died of something
that even a turkey wouldn't die from
then here's one this fellow he was a
doctor's doctor dr martin carter he
almost made it he died at age 57
he got his medical degree from have it
medical school and his phd
in medicine from yale he was autopsied
by the best because he was a doctor's
doctor he said
quote the cause of death was a ruptured
aortic aneurysm said dr jules hirsch
the rockefeller university hospital
unquote what did he die from
copper deficiency see he didn't have
expensive urine either then here's an
attorney
she was so famous she was from detroit
age 44 ellen joyce alter
she was in the new york times obituary
she made the big time
and uh of course she probably had steel
buns because she belonged to one of
those private health clubs
all these gals want steel buns you know
doing their little exercises
but she didn't have expensive urine
because she died of a ruptured cerebral
aneurysm when they don't do an autopsy
the symptoms could be
called a stroke or a subdural hemorrhage
but very frequently they're caused by a
ruptured aneurysm which is a copper
deficiency she didn't have expensive
urine
how many of you here have ever heard of
a guy by the name of stuart berger
stuart berger he he wrote five
best-selling books on health and diets
and nutrition
he got his medical degree from tufts
medical school which is a very fine
medical school
in boston not too far away from harvard
and the books he wrote included the
southampton diet for weight loss
he wrote forever young 20 years younger
in 20 weeks and how to be your own
nutritionist
and he died at age 40. how'd you like to
follow his dietary practices
he died at age 40 of cardiomyopathy
which is a selenium deficiency
the same causes white muscle disease or
our
stiff lamb disease and any farmer can go
to a feed store and get
selenium pellets or selenium injections
things like celatoc and bosey
and so forth and dr stuart berger a guy
who wrote five best-selling books on
nutrition
died of a nutritional deficiency he
didn't have expensive urine
you can prevent totally prevent
cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a day
and if we don't do it we're malignant
dumb i like to call it your malignant
dumb if you don't take in 10 cents a day
worth of
selenium it's a waste of your life
that's one of those landmines you can
avoid the medical treatment of choice
for cardiomyopathy as a heart transplant
cause 750 thousand dollars i want you to
think about that they get the heart free
from a donor
they get the blood free for the surgery
from the relatives
they used 2.50 cents worth of suture
material
and they charges 750 000 for that
procedure
now six months ago in la when they had
the earthquake they were putting people
in jail for 60 and 90 days for price
gouging for selling these terrified
people
a gallon of water for four dollars they
put them in jail for price gouging for
selling them a gallon of water for four
bucks
now to me that's entrepreneurialism you
know that's being in business for
yourself if you had a
way to distill water and make water and
you had a car and you could get in there
and sell those people a gallon of water
for four bucks hey more power to you
because if you go to a 7-eleven and buy
a quart of evian water it's a dollar
twenty-nine
so four of those courts is five bucks
kind of interesting isn't it
they said it was price gouging because
those people were terrified well talk
about a person who needs a new heart
they're terrified
750 000 we should put those doctors in
jail
but we bow to them because oh that's
high-tech medicine
out of 270 million people in america you
save about 50 a year
is that cost effective i don't think so
dr stewart berger didn't have expensive
urine
now here's the last one and many of you
may know this woman
her name is dr gail clark she was age 47
she was the chief cardiologist of the
west saint louis county
group of hospitals she was the chief
cardiologist for the
st mary's health center in richmond
heights in st louis county she was age
47.
guess what she died from heart attack a
cardiomyopathy heart attack
you can just see her walking down the
hall she's got the stethoscope around
her neck you know this is their
little status symbol got my stethoscope
around my neck back when i was in school
they folded it up very
bravely and put it in their pocket boom
she falls down she has a heart attack
right in the hall
and of course the nurses scoop her up
and put her on a gurney and they call
the technicians in another doctor code
three code three
code blue whatever it is and they whip
her into the room
and uh you can hear them let's say
you're a cardiac patient you're laying
there you're all hooked up to the
monitors and the ivs and
you hear them say okay tear clothes off
okay stand back didn't work turn it up
stand back
and then you hear that terrible sound
when you know that the
treatment didn't work
the flat line when you know the heart is
gone and everybody walks out of the room
dejected and you say
nurse nurse what happened next door and
she says well
your cardiologist you know the chief
cardiologist at this hospital age 47 dr
gail clark
just died of a cardiomyopathy heart
attack you can see all the patients are
holding their gowns
and they're running out of that hospital
leaving their watches and their shoes
and their
checkbooks and everything they're
plastic credit cards because they don't
want to get what dr
gail clark got to me the reader's digest
is a magazine that never says anything
negative or bad about anybody or any
group
it's the sweetest little magazine that
ever was the september 1993
issue features an article that says can
you trust your doctor
it lists 12 ways the doctors scam your
money and i'll let you read 11 of them
yourself i'll give you the worst one
in addition to their income from office
fees and surgical fees and lab fees and
hospitalization
doctors get a kickback from the labs and
the the x-ray labs and clinics
and hospitals they get a kickback of 421
dollars every time
they send you in for a cat scan or an
mri
and doctors tell you oh we do that
because we're practicing defensive
medicine because if i missed something
you know one in 10 billion you're gonna
sue me so i do this
just to protect myself well if it was
just to protect themselves and you knew
them and they knew you
ninety percent of the people say oh just
skip a doc if you don't really think
it's necessary let's save the money
but they got something more than
defensive medicine to worry about
they get 421 bucks in a kickback for
every time they send you in
for an mri or a cat scan well when i
practice for 12 years up in portland
somebody come to me with a terrible
headache never had one i just walk up to
them and tap them on the sinuses and if
they
collapse to their knees i know they had
a sinus headache oh doc why'd you do
that well i just wanted that's a cheap
lab test
then if they had thank you if they had
blood dripping out of their nose it'd
take a 35
x-ray to see if they had a cancer in
there 35 bucks in a free lab test
as opposed to 421 bucks if i wanted to
make that 421 bucks i'd have been a good
thief
what i'd have done i had to build a
shoot right into that cat scan machine
because i knew how to build shoots
living on a farm
and i'd gone out in the street and i'd
got every homeless person i'd line them
up in them shoots
and i'd put soup and a big mac at the
end of that tube you know
i say i'm going to get buy you a dollar
fifty dinner i'm a good guy i'm going to
buy you a dollar 50 dinner you just got
to go through this shoot go through that
tube and you get your
sandwich and your soup man they'd be
flowing through there maybe 100 a day
and i could start adding some things up
it'd be a lot of fun anyway the average
hundred doctor gets thousand six hundred
and sixty dollars a year in cat scan
kickbacks
a quarter of a million dollars a year
and any other industry if
you do that politicians lawyers
businessmen stockbrokers they get put in
jail
but doctors it's okay because insurance
pays for it we don't mind if they steal
us blind
it's free remember i told you i was
going to tell you about pica
pike is a funny disease pica i'm not
talking about the type style
that you see in typewriters and
computers but pika is a disease that
farmers know about
uh in horses it's called cribbing when
they chew on the feed bunk the wooden
feed bunk
you know you better give them some
minerals otherwise they're gonna eat
that feed bunk
and cattle dairy cattle especially where
they're losing lots of minerals through
their milk
all the time intense of milking you'll
see them picking up big rocks in the
creek and chewing on them or they'll
chew on barbed wire or maybe you'll see
them walking
down through a path with a deer bone in
their mouth or something or a shingle
that's called pica and a good farmer
husband dreaming knows you better give
them some minerals otherwise they're
going to eat the barn or something
in human beings we see this at funny
times pregnant women are notorious for
pica
the middle of the night they'll elbow
their husband and say hey you better get
up i want some
pickles and ice cream they're craving
minerals because that fetus is pulling
minerals out of their body
and they need some more minerals and so
it's it's recognized as a craving for
things like
sweets and salt we see this in pregnant
women i used to have people come to my
practice and they say doctor i need to
go see a shrink i said why is that
well i wake up in the middle of the
night and i go outside with a spoon and
i eat dirt
and no that's okay just make sure it's
clean dirt
then they say my kid sits there with a
kitty litter box between his legs and
he has a spoon and he's eating that
stuff out of the kitty litter box
and then in housing projects little kids
will eat lead paint
off the walls and they get lead poison
get learning disabilities and bone
problems and anemia and
we're good so we spend five million
dollars to scrape the lead paint off of
there and repaint it with latex paint
and all we have to do is give those kids
10 cents a day worth of minerals be
better for them and save us 5 million
bucks
it's your tax money and if we allow them
to throw them away
those dollars is kind of interesting if
you have a selenium deficiency
and you don't want to wait until you get
cardiomyopathy and drop dead from a
heart attack to recognize it
if you look on your hands and look in
the mirror in your face if you have
liver spots or age spots and i see
quite a few from here you have an early
selenium deficiency that's called free
radical damage
and fortunately for you if you recognize
that and you start taking in some
selenium in four to six months those
will go away
you'll reverse that in four to six
months and when they go away on the
outside they're going away on the inside
and your brain and your heart and your
liver
and your kidneys and if you have low
blood sugar how many in this room have
low blood sugar anybody in here have low
blood sugar okay about ten percent
how many have you ever seen a
hyperactive kid who gets on sugar
okay about everybody in the room people
who have sugar problems
are like alcoholics there's good ones
and bad ones you know the good
alcoholics are one when they get two
drinks they just go off in a corner and
go to sleep right
same way with somebody with low blood
sugar they eat a big meal or they eat a
piece of pie three hours later
they clunk out and go to sleep then
there's bad alcoholics they're the one
that gets two drinks in them and they
get violent and raged and they want to
fight everybody
punch holes in the wall you know big
brave fellows and they kick their wife
and kick the dog and take the chainsaw
and cut their neighbor's tree down and
all these wild things and drive reckless
down the roads and kill people
those are the bad drunks well people who
have blood sugar problems there's bad
blood sugar people too they're a little
crazy
okay i don't know how many of you
remember the twinkie defense
right remember somebody murdered two
people and he claimed he ate a twinkie
three hours before he murdered him so
they let him off because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar
now don't any of you try that well
chromium and vanadium deficiency will
result
in these sugar problems low blood sugar
and if you let it go on for any length
of time you develop diabetes
chromium and vanadium then a tin
deficiency the early symptoms of a tin
deficiency
are male pattern baldness i see a lot of
tin deficiency in this room
yes and if you let it go on for any
length of time
you get deafness then there's a boron
deficiency and you gals should know
about boron
because it helps you keep the calcium
you take in in your bones so you don't
get osteoporosis
boron also it helps you make estrogen
it helps you fellows make testosterone
if you don't take in
enough boron you ladies are going to
suffer miserably
going through menopause okay you're
going to have all those terrible
symptoms
you fellas don't get enough boron can't
make testosterone you won't know whether
to lead or follow on the dance floor
you're going to be confused
she's saying he's got a boron deficiency
the first symptoms of a zinc deficiency
is you lose your sense of smell and your
taste
say oh you know food just doesn't taste
good anymore and you don't have a cold
or anything like that you say
your wife says well aren't you excited
about dinner i spent the whole day in
the kitchen cooking dinner i said well i
didn't smell anything when i walked in
you know he's got a zinc deficiency
in laboratory animals there's some seven
rare earths these rare earths or trace
minerals you need in
lesser amounts than you need trace
minerals and they actually double the
lifespan
of laboratory animals they've not been
proven in humans yet but i'm not going
to wait 500
years for doctors to approve it they're
still arguing over vitamin c
and calcium right so i'm just going to
do it didn't kill any laboratory animals
just doubles their life and it's not a
drug
these rare earths are called lanthanum
praseodymium neodymium sumerium
europium yitrabium and thulium there
must be a reason why they're
named after old testament cities well
remember i told you we needed 90
nutrients
we need 60 minerals we need 16 vitamins
12 essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids
and of course we're lucky in that plants
as a group can make most vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids
plants can do that because they just
take carbon out of the air and make
carbon chains to make vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids
but you have to eat 15 to 25 different
plants a day in the right combinations
to make this happen theoretically it's
possible that most americans don't do it
the average american thinks if they eat
some potato buds out of a betty crocker
box or eating a vegetable
okay so you got to be careful what
you're considering a vegetable
then of course people want to do right
by their doctor and they eat low-fat
turkey breasts and they put a half a jar
of mayonnaise on there
and they put it between two slices of
wonder styrofoam bread
remember that stuff you can insulate
your house with and put your shoes when
you get a hole and shoe
i remember when i was a kid there's a
lot of fun because we have wonder bread
we didn't have tvs back then on the farm
we didn't even have dryers that went
round and round so the only thing you
could do in the winter time was
sit in the kitchen and wandered a loaf
of wonder bread and had the blue and red
and green
yellow balloons on there and if you read
the labels many times as i do you know
it said things like
helps build bodies at 12 ways and about
15 years later the fda made them change
it to help build your body eight ways
now if you go to the store and look at
wonder bread wrappers it just says
wonder bread
so it kind of gives you a clue
so even though this is theoretically
possible it's not likely to happen that
you're going to get your vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids in proper
proportions
from your diet and so if your life is as
valuable to you
as mine is to me and my children's my
grandchildren's is
to me i would make sure that i take in
all my vitamins and amino acids and
fatty acids because i guarantee you
won't make it to 120
if you don't you're just not going to do
it
now minerals are another story we have a
tragic story when it comes to minerals
because
plants cannot make minerals in any way
shape or form and if they're not in the
soil anymore they're not
in our plants our farm soils and our
rain soils are depleted of minerals and
the crops the grains the fruits and the
vegetables and the nuts that are grown
on these depleted farm
and rain soils are minerally deficient
the people who eat them
get mineral deficiency diseases and the
only way to prevent and cure them is
with mineral supplements
do you think it's gotten any better no
it has not gotten any better it's only
gotten worse
and the reason is if you guys do what we
did and people continue to do
is we put npk on our land nitrogen
phosphorous potassium and you see it
as these three numbers and many
combinations of
ratios and these represent percentages
of these three nutrients nitrogen
phosphorus potassium and those of you
who don't
have any experience on farms the reason
why we do this is farmers get paid for
tons and bushels
there's no subsidy that encourages
people to put 60 minerals back in the
soil you get paid for tons and bushels
and for 40 bucks an acre
you can get the maximum yield in tons
and bushels it only takes five to ten
years to deplete the land of minerals
because every time you harvest a crop
those plants pull minerals out of the
soil many pounds
per acre every time you haul a crop out
so soon
those minerals are gone and if you only
put back in three and you take out 60
it's like a checking account if you only
put three bucks in your checking account
every month and write checks for 60
what's going to happen to your checks
boing boing boing they bounce exactly
well i can tell you that our health is
bouncing right now to the tune of 1.2
trillion dollars a year it's our
responsibility each and every one of us
to be
responsible for our health and
consciously take in these minerals
i have a lot of people ask me what did
these people do thousands of years ago
they didn't even have commercial
fertilizers what did they do these
societies that had long lived people and
whatnot
i want you to think about the egyptians
the chinese people from india that lived
around these great rivers the nile river
the ganges river
the yalu river in china and what used to
happen was every year or so would flood
just like it did here in northern
missouri
last year and every time it flooded
guess what would happen it would bring
silt or rock dust from mountains from
500 or thousand miles away
and those people would pray to every god
they had the water god the sky god the
wind god the rock god
to flood we pray don't flood they used
to pray to flood
because they had their floods during the
winter time and would put
silt and minerals back in the soil and
their grain was very valuable
king phillip who is the father of
alexander the great
married the 12 year old child queen of
egypt cleopatra she didn't look like
elizabeth taylor all made up in
beautiful costumes she was a little
flat-chested teeny bopper not very sexy
but philip married her because
she controlled the best wheat in the
world and if he wanted his macedonian
army to conquer the world
through his son alexander the great he
needed the best wheat in the world so
you could march 20 hours
a day fight for six hours and win if
they used the wheat from the depleted
soils in greece they couldn't go
20 minutes without saying mommy pick me
up can you imagine these big greek
soldiers oh my legs hurt
pick me up and so they knew the best
place to get wheat
was from egypt it was those floods that
gave them those minerals and all those
cultures
that came up with all the great art and
all the great technology came from those
places because they had more
intelligence because they had more
nutrition more minerals i heard somebody
say very good
we're getting the picture well what i'm
going to do here is i'm just going to
pick out a couple of minerals
just a couple of them so you get the
idea it applies to all of them
let's just pick out a common one like
calcium everybody knows about calcium
calcium
deficiency will result in something like
147 different diseases
they're just different names they're
named after people like bells palsy
you know everybody knows about that one
side of your face sags it's not as true
stroke it just affects your facial
muscles
it's caused by calcium deficiency we'll
talk about in a little bit
but everybody knows about this one
osteoporosis
it's the number 10 killer of adults in
the united states it's very expensive it
costs you thirty five thousand dollars
each
for each hip to replace it's okay it's
free
insurance will pay for it cost you
seventy thousand dollars for both hips
as expensive as it is and number ten
killer remember
mrs skeets from radford virginia age 115
years of age she died of
complications of a fall we don't have
osteoporosis in animals and it's because
of farmers we don't have osteoporosis in
animals
goes like this you have a a pasture with
100 cows in
it and this year you didn't have any
calves you can't repay your operating
loan you're in trouble
right because you paid for the feed and
the vet bill and mowed the pasture and
fertilized and maintained the fence and
fed the cows and all this and the other
you don't have any calves you can't pay
back the operating load and make any
money so you call the vet out and you
say
do i get rid of these cows what happened
here and he examines the cows there's
nothing wrong with them
he says let me look at the bull he said
aha here's your problem that bull has
osteoporosis of
both hips can't breed the cows didn't
have any calves he said i'll tell you
what though
he says you give me seventy thousand
dollars he says i'll put two new hips in
that bull next year you'll have some
calves
well the first thing that farmer says is
stand back doc boom
he blows that bull away with a deer
rifle and while the kids are grinding
the bull up
with a grinder and cutting roasts and
steaks off that bull the farmer is
chewing on a straw and saying now doc
pushes stetson up a little bit and he
says you know i wasn't going to pay you
70 000
for that old boy he said i get a new
bull every year for 70 years for that
he says but every once while i get a
bullet throws good calves i'd like to
keep him is there any way i can prevent
that osteoporosis thing for happening
to a good boy he says well yeah he says
if you'll give a bull calf 10 cents
worth of calcium
every day after he's weaned he'll never
get osteoporosis first now wait a minute
doc
you mean if i give that bull 10 cents a
day worth of calcium
from the time he's weaned i can prevent
a seventy thousand dollar
disaster oh yeah it's that simple he
says you mean all i have to do is give
up a half a cup of coffee a day to do
that
he says yeah that's it he says i choose
that one he says i'll give up the half a
cup of coffee
and that's what we have to think like
then there's receding gums
dentists and periodontists will tell you
that if you want to prevent and cure
receding gums you better floss and brush
after every meal
if you believe that works i have some
oceanfront property in montana to sell
you
if you all know your geography you know
that doesn't work now as a veterinarian
i've seen hundreds of thousands of
animals of all kinds mice rats
rabbits dogs cats sheep pigs horses
lions and tigers and bears and they
don't get receding gums
and they don't floss now they do get
funky breath but they don't get receding
gums
well if you want to smell something you
just let a camel
breathe on you boy
well the reason we don't have receding
gums and livestock is because
we've dealt with the osteoporosis
problem receding gums is not a
deficiency of flossing it's in fact
osteoporosis of the jaw bones and the
facial bones so if you have gingivitis
or receding gums
you have advanced osteoporosis those
bones around your teeth are melting away
a little bit by a little bit every day
and if you take your teeth out at night
and put them in a glass next to your bed
and that fizzy stuff
you have major advanced osteoporosis
because all your bone
has melted away then there's arthritis
we talked about that a little bit
earlier remember the chicken cartilage
85 percent of all arthritis
is caused by osteoporosis of the joint
ends of the bones you're talking about
degenerative arthritis osteoarthritis
sciatica lumbago rheumatism
all those sorts of things they're caused
by osteoporosis of the joint ends of the
bones i want you to think about
something for a minute
if you don't take a pain reliever or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis
let's say you get arthritis of the hips
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit aren't you you're going to
get a cane or a walker or
crutches you're going to favor it and so
you don't put any weight on it
i want you to think about that for just
second because then i want you to think
about driving your tractor in a field or
driving a mercedes down the highway
either one doesn't matter
whichever you love more let's say you
didn't put the nut on that oil pan real
tight and all the oil drained out
and that light on the dashboard comes on
says i'm getting hot you better give me
some oil
and that light irritates you so you stop
you open up the hood you get your
clippers out you know your fence
clippers and you
clip the wire to that light you close
the hood and you just keep driving
would you do that to your tractor or
your mercedes no you wouldn't
but we take those pain relievers for
arthritis and we go out there and square
dance
and do the texas two step and do our
five mile walks in our aerobics
that pill works real good doc because it
killed my pain and you're just wearing
that thing off faster and faster
then your doctor is really going to get
rich because you need joint replacement
surgery
then there's hypertension this is one of
my favorites so i'll put a star over
here
hypertension is high blood pressure
what's the first nutritional thing that
a doctor will tell you to give up
nutritionally when you get high blood
pressure give up
salt everybody knows that one has been
ingrained in our head
well they must think we're dumber than
cows because what's the first thing you
put out for your livestock is about that
big a salt block no farmer
is going to be economically viable if
you don't put a salt block out for your
livestock they're going to die
kind of your veterinary bills are going
to go crazy but we're supposed to
believe that we don't need salt you can
get everything you need out of your
lettuce and your whole wheat bread and
stuff like that
well don't believe that one either if
you believe that i got some more
oceanfront property in montana for you
they took 30 million dollars of your tax
money and two years ago after a 20-year
study they came out and said that they
took 5000 people with high blood
pressure they took them off their
medication
and put them on a reduced salt diet a
restricted salt diet
and they all died no big surprise but
somebody got a phd degree and everybody
was happy right
but when they looked at this results
they said that oh only
99.7 percent of the people didn't get
any results
from that before they died 0.3 percent
did get some result dropped their blood
pressure one point before they died by
restricting their salt
so the referees who judged that article
said oh doesn't matter you might as well
let high blood pressure patients
eat salted peanuts and dill pickles and
salt their food to taste because it
doesn't matter
in fact worrying about the salt is more
stress than taking the salt
then they had a control group with 5000
people with high blood pressure and they
doubled their rda of calcium
and they stopped the experiment in six
weeks because 85 percent of them were
cured of their high blood pressure just
by doubling their calcium intake
now they didn't cold turkey stopped
their high blood pressure medication
but what they did was they went to the
doctor and says you don't need this
medication anymore
what are you doing well i'm on this
experiment where i double my calcium
intake
anybody get a recall notice from your
doctor saying it's okay to salt your
food to taste and
please do double your calcium intake
anybody get that not a single
one that's very interesting then of
course there's uh insomnia that's where
you roll around all night
you wake up in the morning you're more
tired when you went to bed that's
insomnia of course doctors have two
treatments for that they have
halcyon which is a sleeping pill and
they have barbiturates they kill about
ten thousand people a year with
overdoses of those things but that's
okay
it's in prescription and they're
watching out for us and remember
george bush when he went to japan they
gave him some helsion so he could sleep
on the way to japan because of the time
difference
and when he woke up one of the side
effects of halcyon is nausea and
vomiting
i don't know how you say it in japanese
but it was very dramatic on world tv
right not very presidential
and so i'm sure that's why he lost the
election because he puked over that
japanese ambassador
and then of course there's kidney stones
and then there's a bone spurs heel
spurs and calcium deposits again
physicians will tell you
the first thing to give up nutritionally
is calcium and dairy because they have
this foolish belief
the stupid belief the ignorant belief
that the calcium
in kidney stones bone spurs heel spurs
and calcium deposits come from
your diet when instead it only comes
from your bones when you have a raging
osteoporosis
and when you get these things you need
more calcium not less
then there's cramps and twitches you
wake up in the middle of the night and
your foot is all cramped up around your
neck and you say
lord take me from the knee down i'm not
going to make it till morning
we've all experienced that that's very
common
then there's pms premenstrual syndrome
you know the emotional and physical
stuff the medical treatment of choice
for pms is what we call a hysterical
ectomy it's been shortened to
hysterectomy that's a hundred year old
treatment the doctors do about 285
thousand
unnecessary hystericalectomies a year
but it makes mercedes payments so they
do them
even the ama said they're unnecessary
but they don't take their licenses away
and people keep going to them you
imagine a poor woman in her 30s
she says doc you got to do something
every time i go out to hang up the
clothes my neighbor's kids run down the
basement screaming which
my own kids think i'm crazy my husband's
leaving me i'ma lose my job you got to
do something
well the university of california san
diego came out three years ago now and
said if you just double the rda of
calcium intake
you get rid of 85 percent of the
emotional and physical symptoms of pms
and when that came out there were huge
lines around the health food stores
around the blocks and people had sleep
in bags
because they closed before they all got
their calcium and every person in line
was a man
they were there for their daughters and
their girlfriends and their wives and
things like that
okay and lastly is low back pain 85
percent of americans get low back pain
whether you work on a computer or you
unload
hay or you drive big trucks doesn't
matter low back is a big problem
low back is just osteoporosis of the
vertebrae whether you have a disc
problem or whatnot
because if your disc doesn't have
anything to hold on to
your vertebrae melted away what's going
to happen to the disc
especially if you have a copper
deficiency because they're made out of
elastic fibers
they go like a water balloon with a lot
of pressure on them i just want you to
look at this quickly before we do the
last mineral
low back you go to an orthopedic surgeon
or rheumatologist you might get a
muscle relaxant you might get valium and
a muscle relaxant you get a
laminectomy you get your vertebrae fuse
you might get a disc operation they
don't tell you 75 percent of time you'll
never be the same again
right pms you go to your ob gyn
you can go to an internist you can go to
a family counselor a shrink or divorce
attorney
cramps and twitches you go to a
neurologist you go to a sports medicine
doctor an internist
bone spurs heel spurs calcium deposits
you go to a rheumatologist
an orthopedic surgeon or a podiatrist
kidney stones you go to a urologist an
internist or a surgeon insomnia you go
to schranker a
sleep clinic or an internist
hypertension you go to a cardiologist an
internist
or a surgeon arthritis a rheumatologist
a orthopedic surgeon an internist
receding gums you go to a dentist or a
periodontist
osteoporosis you go to all those health
specialists including a tum salesman
for nothing more than a calcium
deficiency would cost you 10 cents a day
to deal with
now on the average because americans
have insurance and we have medicare and
medicaid
we spend on the average twenty five
thousand dollars to two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
and we undergo five to ten surgical
procedures a year
for a calcium deficiency and we beg the
doctors to do it
we beg the doctors to do it well it's
our choice
the last one i'll share with you is
diabetes
everybody's touched by diabetes it's the
number three cause of death in adults in
the united states
number three cause of death and it has
terrible complications and side effects
diabetes
the side effects include blindness of
many kinds
then there's a kidney failure with
dialysis and kidney transplant there's
cardiovascular
disease of all kinds and of course that
contributes the number one cause of
death
then there's amputations everybody ought
to have one of those because they're
totally paid for
in their health thing because they
assume that you're not just going to get
one because you want to get everything
on your health benefits
and then you shorten your life because
if you have diabetes on the average
you have a shorter lifespan than someone
who doesn't have diabetes now
we learned in 1957 in the animal
industry that we could prevent and cure
diabetes with two trace minerals that's
a pretty profound statement that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with two
trace minerals in 1957 and animals
it was published in federation
proceedings which is the official
journal of the
american science the national institutes
of health
the official monthly journal is august
1957.
well the two trace minerals that you can
get to prevent and cure this
are chromium and vanadium vanadium alone
according to the university of vancouver
british columbia medical school
vanadium alone will replace insulin in
adult onset diabetics which represent 85
percent of all diabetics
of course they can't quit their insulin
cold turkey they got to gradually wean
off of it
takes four to six months for most people
to slowly wean off of insulin if they're
taking in
adequate amounts of chromium and
vanadium now to me this is criminal
because if you write to hill's packing
company that makes science dot dog food
right over here in topeka kansas so they
manufacture science diet dog food and
other science diet product high tech
foods for animals
if you write them and say how many
minerals exactly is in science diet for
dog food they'll write you back and say
there's 40 minerals
you write checkerboard square in st
louis ralston korean say just how many
minerals
are in your wrap pellets for laboratory
rats and they'll say there's 28 minerals
i'll give anybody in this room a crisp
new hundred dollar bill if you can find
me a human
infant formula in a grocery store that
has more than 11.
so our dogs get 40 minerals remember
that's what mike murphy was saying his
dog never seems to get sick
because he's getting this canned dog
food with all these vitamins and
minerals in there
so our dogs get farty minerals our rats
get 28 minerals and our human infants
get 11.
is that fair no that's called
fraud it doesn't matter if you're
talking about sma
similac isomil prosoybe in fact that's
why they call simulac similac because it
lacks everything
okay if i've convinced you that you have
to consciously take in
all the minerals yourself that you can't
depend on your food
and certainly can't depend on anything
that's boxed or packaged or bottled
there's three types of minerals that you
have to be concerned about one is
metallic minerals
and metallic minerals are essentially
ground up rocks metallic minerals are
things like oyster shell eggshell
dolomite limestone uh
calcium carbonate clays of various kinds
mount marulinite clay
seabed minerals tums they're only eight
to twelve percent absorbable when you
reach age thirty five to forty it drops
down to three to five percent
and i have to tell you a story here i
ran into a guy at a meeting like this up
at grand rapids michigan
and this fellow owns a port-a-potty
business you know that's that green or
blue-colored outhouse
man if we'd only had one of those back
when i was a kid we had these ones with
splinters you know in the wood
he said i see something that that
describes that in my port-a-potty
business i said what's that
he says well we take those things back
to the shop to clean him out with a
pressure hose
he says we put a quarter inch grid
underneath them because kids throw rocks
and sticks and toys in there
and if we don't put a grid there it
blocks up the sewer system it costs us
thousands of dollars to fix it
every time we clean one of those out we
find hundreds of vitamin tablets
i said well how do you know their
vitamin tablets he says well it's really
easy
he says right on the coating it says
theragram m one a day centrum
he says come here he takes me out in the
back of the shop and there's this
literal mountain
of all these vitamin pills he got out of
his porta-potties if you read the labels
on those multiples they say
your iron it comes in the form of iron
oxide
what is iron oxide rust
you might as well just go out to an old
railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it
and you're going to get your iron
supplement that's what they're giving
you i'll show you how bad it is if you
take something like calcium lactate was
it which is a common
metallic mineral uh let's say it's a
calcium tablet calcium lactate a
thousand milligrams
if you take two of those you're not
getting two thousand milligrams of
calcium in fact i have people all the
time say
well i took lots of calcium doc i hear
you on the radio talking about calcium
and arthritis and
i took two thousand milligrams of
calcium a day didn't help my arthritis
in fact it got worse
and so what kind of calcium you're
taking they said calcium lactate well
there's your problem
because only 250 milligrams of that is
metallic calcium
so let's say you absorb 10 percent of
that then the other 750 milligrams is
lactose or milk sugar
so 10 percent of 250 is 25 so if you
take
two of those tablets you're not getting
2 000 you're getting 50 milligrams
so to get what you need you need to take
90 of those tablets a day you need to
take 30 with each meal and you got 59
more minerals to go
then there's those people who want to do
things naturally let's see if you can do
anything good with 10 pounds of spinach
and let's be fair let's see if you can
get a thousand milligrams of magnesium
i pick magnesium because in green leafy
vegetables you have a lot of magnesium
because of the chlorophyll right it's
part of the chlorophyll molecule and any
pound of anything you got 454 grams
and 10 pounds of spinach you got 4 540
grams
of which most of that 97 is water unless
you have one gram
of chlorophyll and that 10 pounds of
spinach there's 50 milligrams of
magnesium
you got to divide that into the thousand
you want you get a factor of 20 which
you multiply times the 10.
you have to eat 200 pounds of spinach
you got 58 more minerals to go
okay so you got to be a pretty big
person to accomplish all this
even as big as i am you can't get it
done so i prefer to supplement
rather than do those things then of
course during the 60s the agricultural
industry came up with
chelated minerals because farmers aren't
dumb enough to pay for a dollar if
something
goes into an animal's mouth and have 99
cents come out in the manure
i have to really thank farmers for being
that clever and chelated minerals are
just metallic minerals
with an amino acid or protein or enzyme
wrapped around
the metal atom and increased the
absorbability to 40 percent
then the health food industry jumped on
that right away because it was a major
improvement in absorbability of minerals
the most efficient way to absorb
minerals is liquid
they're very small particle size are 7
000 times
smaller than a red blood cell and
they're negatively charged so you
actually have an electrical or magnetic
gradient that concentrates these
minerals
plants have a very interesting part to
play in colloidal minerals
remember we said that plants cannot
create minerals
they're not in the soil plants can't
make them at any rate metallic minerals
are taken up by plants when they're in
the soil plants convert them
in their tissues to colloidal minerals
and this is how we store minerals in our
body this is how we use minerals in our
body
this is how we transport minerals from
the storage place to their site of use
in the colloidal farm well our plants
our crops don't have much in the way of
colloidal minerals in them because we
don't have any metallic minerals
in our soil are these minerals important
you bet your life they're important
[Applause]
information and statements regarding
dietary supplements discussed have not
been evaluated by the food and drug
administration and are not intended to
diagnose tree
cure or prevent any disease
thank you for listening to this
presentation and remember to contact
the person that sent this to you for
more presentations and books that go
into greater detail
go to doc wallockmedia.com and be well
these statements have not been evaluated
by the fda
these products are not intended to
diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease
the opinions expressed in this
informational program
are the express opinions of joel d
wallick bsdvmnd
are not a replacement for proper medical
advice and treatment
in all cases we recommend you contact
your physician directly
regarding any medical conditions